see span is brought to you by your cable
or satellite provider
Washington journal continues joining us
from New York Jeff Ringo who was a
former FBI agent in the New York field
office here to talk about a couple of
issues and we'll start with the shooting
in Florida mr. Ringle wits reported that
if you look at the front pages of the
newspapers for example the Washington
Post warning signs scrutinized in
Florida attack attempts tipsters call to
the FBI and concerns voiced by neighbors
in school fuel debate over law
enforcement response what's your
reaction to that apparently he said on
YouTube I'm going to be a professional
school shooter the YouTube user was
Nicolas Cruz the FBI was alerted to this
what's your reaction well first I
haven't seen today's papers but
something like this the FBI gets lots of
leads that come into the office from
people who see something they don't like
and they report it to the FBI from what
I understand the FBI tried to identify
who Nicolas Cruz on what was at Facebook
or YouTube was they could not there are
different steps or different levels of
investigation and there are different
investigative steps that can be taken in
each one of those investigative levels
and so in this case somebody reported
the YouTube the FBI can do so much work
but it's underneath it's in the
assessment phase and they couldn't use
legal processes such as grand jury
subpoenas or search warrants to get
further into identifying who Cruz was
explain that a little bit more because
the Washington Post says that after that
tip was made two FBI agents interviewed
the caller who was Mississippi bail
bondsman Ben vennett the next day the
bureau checked public and law
enforcement databases for anyone by
Cruz's name who might be of concern the
FBI said but could not identify the
person who left the document so explain
when you say you only can do so much
there are let's say three levels of
investigative steps that the FBI can do
in this case the caller Ben he called it
in from I think you said Mississippi
that's an assessment the FBI can use
public databases their FBI databases
law enforcement databases to run that
name or to run that handle or to run
anything that could hopefully identify
who Cruz was by doing this they can see
if there have been other reports similar
reports on a person named Cruz if Cruz
had already been identified and that
would then give the investigators more
to delve into when they're doing their
investigation but without any real
concrete information and and I've seen
this from investigations I've had where
somebody makes a very generic bland
threat I'm going to blow up the tunnel
but doesn't identify which tunnel what
state when where how there's not a lot
the FBI can do to follow up on that and
so I think the FBI did everything that
they could legally do by their doctrine
and by their procedures to try to
identify him and when they could do
nothing further that's when they have to
close that lead out and the Washington
Post notes five months later he walked
into that school in Florida what is
missing when the FBI is trying to
connect dots because here's the Wall
Street Journal front-page shooters
showed warning signs the teen left
behind a trail of worrying signs that in
hindsight seemed to have gone unheeded
concerned neighbors called the police
classmates said he was obsessed with
guns and campus security considered Hurd
considered him troubled so why are those
why is that information not given to the
FBI or can the FBI cannot access it when
they're doing when they're following up
on a tip what more needs to be done do
you think well when people are going to
local law enforcement and saying my
teenage neighbor is troubled and that's
all they tell the police the police
really don't have much they can do they
can go talk to the individual if he's
underage they may need to have a parent
involved well they discuss with that
that individual they can do some of
their own investigation but if the
information is going to local law
enforcement local law enforcement is the
first place that this can be addressed
you know because when you talk about the
FBI that's federal right and so we're
looking at across state lines and
nationally if local law enforcement is
being told that this individual in high
school is
trouble the school security the local
police they could possibly come up with
a plan to sit down talk to crews try to
figure out who he is and what he's up to
but again until certain trip wires are
crossed
law enforcement sort of has their hand
tied again they can talk to the
individual that can look at the
individual the fact that crews went out
and purchased a weapon and if law of
local law enforcement was already
monitoring him that would be one of
those trip wires that was cross based
upon what he was saying based on that he
just purchased a gun now law enforcement
can be more proactive and get more
investigative steps
well how just how would law and local
law enforcement know that he just
purchased a gun would that be the FBI
tells them no because the FBI is not
told when I take that back when somebody
buys a weapon there should be a
background check you know just basically
a check that the gun dealer has to do to
make sure that the individual doesn't
have a criminal record that will go
through sieges through the the FBI
database on you know criminal records
but that is that is all the FBI doesn't
track people who buy weapons they just
provide the background check for a
criminal check on gun purchases for the
gun dealers and it sounds like Cruz was
able to go in by the weapon and leave
that day so there is no waiting period
like there are in some other states yeah
he he having no criminal record Cruz
cleared an instant background check via
the FBI criminal database right and and
you know and the FBI is in contacting
local law enforcement saying here the
people in your area who just recently
purchased the weapon okay so this point
Cruz was under the radar to everybody
other than locals who interact with him
and and see him as a disturbed
individual nobody else knows who Cruz's
as as far as law enforcement goes right
so if for these local people his
neighbors the police who have been
alerted to him the school officials is
there something that they can do that
gets somebody like him in on the radar
screen so that when he
if he goes to buy a gun that the that
information is is alerted to somebody
right I understand what you're saying
but take a step back so you have an
angry nineteen year old an angry 18 year
old neighbors don't like him because
he's angry he hasn't broken any laws and
and he's authorized to buy that weapon
he has no criminal record and even
though people might not like what he's
saying he's not he's not been deemed
mentally incapable by any authorities he
doesn't have a criminal record those are
sort of the two places that law
enforcement would look to be able to
stop somebody from purchasing a weapon
and even though on the social media
nobody's tracking this person social
media at beforehand because again that's
unless they have an investigation on him
you know nobody's looking into a social
media or what he's saying or what he's
doing
Darren Gill do you have thoughts and
about giving you your experience about
mental health laws in this country the
USA Today says if somebody is
adjudicated mentally defective or has
been committed to a mental institution
he or she is prohibited from possessing
a firearm under federal law but getting
somebody adjudicated mentally defective
or committed do you believe there are
enough laws on the books for that
process to happen I don't know enough
about the mental health laws but taking
a step back when they had the Virginia
University of Virginia shooter a young
student doing very well in school
pressure of school he went out he killed
a bunch of people I forget how long ago
that was if we were to put a black mark
on everybody who goes to counseling
because they're going through stress
because they're having a problem you
know I'm just thinking about former
military people with whom I dealt who
have come home and needed some
counseling to get back into society
because of PTSD or because of the stress
they they encountered while
overseas if all of a sudden we were to
say okay now that person is on our
record and and forever they're not going
to be authorized to get a weapon or
they're not going to be authorized to
get a security background check because
they had mental health problem that's
going to prevent people from seeking
help that they need so it's somewhat of
a double-edged sword I think there can
be more steps more more stops put in
there for purchasing weapons I would
like to see a longer wait period between
when you're going to purchase the weapon
to when you can actually take the weapon
out of the store you know and and also
support other restrictions but you know
the mental health problem is something
that it's stuff for law enforcement to
address and it's tough for the
government to address because you're
sort of stepping into people's
individual rights at some point mm-hmm
the USA Today says the from 1998 to 2014
the FBI rejected over 16,000 potential
gun buyers because a background check
found a mental health adjudication about
1.4 percent of the roughly 1.2 million
background checks that resulted in a
denial let's go to Roni who's in
Southern Pines North Carolina and
independent Ronnie good morning to you
you're on the air with jeff Rangel
former FBI agent good morning yes good
morning thanks for taking my call um I
have a question and then a comment the
question that I have is did somebody
from Tennessee who had the same
Instagram account called get in touch
with the FBI and let them know that
there was this individual who had been
posting these well horrendous posts on
Instagram I'm not privy to the current
investigation I think I read something
similar to that but I can't say for sure
different do you think that background
checks work the current process
background checks for weapons yeah I
think it's just one step of many of that
need to be done I think at the very
least background checks will stop people
with convictions from getting a weapon
and possibly people who
domestic abuse charges leveled against
them and who were convicted of that so I
think that is one step that needs to
continue yes Danny Silver Spring
Maryland a Republican good morning I
think the missing piece in this puzzle
is the mental health institution so
everybody knew Cruz was a ticking time
bomb what they needed to do was
involuntarily lock him up in a mental
institution and you know evaluated him
for like months until he was you know
seemed to be well enough to be on the
streets I mean that we need to
strengthen our mental health
infrastructure each state has to look
into it that's the missing piece if they
would have locked him up involuntarily
humanely and everything then we would
have fix that problem and I think that's
the missing piece
Jeff Ringo well that's interesting when
you we're gonna lock up somebody
involuntarily
that's jailing them and so now you're
getting into the whole civil rights
issue and I know our government I think
under Reagan we kind of gotten rid of
all the mental institutions and so
that's a big big thing to do i do think
that we can offer each state needs to
offer better mental health services to
its population but again that's costly
and who's going to get in and that's not
necessarily going to stop everything
who's to say that Cruz would have
availed themselves to these these
services and again getting back to and
voluntarily putting people into the
mental health facilities they can do
that in some locations I think here in
New York they get the 72 hours of
involuntary I don't say incarceration
but where they can involuntarily put you
into a mental health situation to assess
you but after 72 hours they have to let
you go Wanda and Chattanooga Tennessee a
Democrat tomorrow morning all right I
was a counter feeling sorry for the
young man because
no most of the time there's a problem
before the drill so in this case I'm
gonna think that there's a problem
before the God and the fact that he was
on this world all alone by himself you
know I think that even the children that
I'm hearing on the TV notice that there
is more that could be done in the area
of supporting people who are at hand is
well now who helped falling through the
cracks
and right now I'm hoping that someone
look into the boolean and have a hotline
for that also because I don't know if he
was bullied or not but I do know that
the young man looked as though he was
the third Jeff wrangle do you have any
it just thoughts about bullying the
online social media how social media is
being used in our society and what
impact that has on criminal activity or
crimes being committed well well my
opinion you know I think social media
makes everybody or gives people that the
capability of being a keyboard hero
people can say things without actually
having to face the person or making the
statements to so everybody can be very
brash and you know insult people online
and say things that they would never say
to a person face to face because that
would just be too difficult I think also
social media sometimes is used to help
promote from obscurity to to be an
infamous you know individuals that are
lost and are looking for something and
they use social media you know as their
last hurrah to get their last their last
shot at Fame I see that often it seems
with a lot of like the jihadist
terrorist that will at the last minute
claimed to be Isis or al-qaeda and they
go from obscurity to be in front-page
news for seven days because of that
let's switch gears and talk about
security clearances that we invited you
want to talk about that and I just want
you to explain for our viewers the
process for somebody to get a security
clearance and and what that means and
what level of clearance is available
sure
security clearances basically authorize
a person to have access to to read/write
classified information the different
levels of classification could be
confidential which means whenever is
being written if released to the public
or if released in the wrong person could
have could damage the US national
security secret is the next higher level
and that would result in the release of
that information to the wrong
individuals would create grave damage
and then top secret if that information
is released that would result in and I
forget the exact terms but like
extremely grave damage to national
security so there are different levels
of information that the security
clearance holder has access to in order
to get a security clearance at the
pending it depends on which agency
you're working for if you're working for
the military the DoD will do your your
security clearance background check if
you're working for something in the
Department of Energy they are
responsible for your security background
check and if the buddy coming out of the
executive branch
so White House personnel as well as
federal judge appointments the US
Attorney appointments those will be
handled by the FBI and the FBI will
basically take the sf-86 which is a form
that every applicant needs to fill out
it's a very long detailed report that
the clearance seeker needs to complete
and the person needs to put down every
where they lived within the last ten
years so that there is no break-ins in
time there they have to list for the
past seven years any employment they
have to list any foreign contact any
foreign business any foreign travel you
have to list all your family members you
have to list your spouse's and ex passes
you have to list your financial
situation your military service
basically a background on who you are
because the background check is done to
make sure that your
a trustworthy person with good character
so that we can trust you with the nation
secrets and do does the FBI interview
all the people that you list on that
form yes they do what will happen is
that sf-86 will go to it's all being
driven out of FBI headquarters but it'll
go to a particular field office in my
case I'm at in New York sort of they
were investigating me it would go into
New York field office and then the New
York field office would be responsible
to cut leads out to the other field
offices Stefan's to follow up on people
that I have listed on my sf-86 so they
would have to go out to my brother's out
in Colorado and my sisters out in
Washington and my cousins out in Texas
who would then be approached by FBI
agents in those field offices and
they'll be questioned about my
credibility my trustworthiness and
anything about me why would they for
example interview a landlord
well somebody who doesn't have
day-to-day contact with a person what
are they trying to get at and what types
of questions are they asking people sure
so you go talk to my landlord did I pay
my rent on time did I cause any problems
did I throw wild parties were there any
instances where police had to be called
to my apartment and why were there any
problems with me did I can sort with
suspicious people that looked funny you
know did I was my schedule was it you
know normal or was I a person who went
out mysteriously in the middle of the
night
things that you know landlords great
person who investigate because they
don't know me possibly personally but
they've observed my actions and that's
what the FBI wants to say is okay so
what Who am I and what am i doing I want
to show our viewers and have you react
to the FBI director for director
Christopher Wright testifying on Capitol
Hill on Tuesday and here's his exchange
with Senator Ron Wyden of Oregon on the
security process and timeline for the
former senior staffer Rob Porter the
background investigation process
involves fairly elaborate
of standards guidelines protocols
agreements etc that have been in place
for 20-plus years and I'm quite
confident that in this particular
instance the FBI followed established
protocols so was the White House
informed that this could affect his
security clearance that's a yes or no I
can't get into the content of what was
briefed the what what what I can tell
you is that the FBI submitted a partial
report on the investigation in question
in March and then a completed background
investigation in late July that is soon
thereafter we received requests for
follow-up inquiry and we did the
follow-up and provided that information
in November and that we administrative
it closed the file in January and then
earlier this month we received some
additional information and we passed
that on as well different goal what do
you make of the process and timeline of
the FBI's background check on Rob Porter
sounds good it sounds too low and I'm
sure was thorough I think one point that
needs to be made is people got to
understand that it's not the FBI that
issues the security clearance the the
FBI is working for the client in this
case the client would be the White House
the FBI does the background
investigation verifies and vets all the
information found on that sf-86 and
during the process that are going to be
talking to multiple people to get a
better idea of who the person is that is
looking for the security clearance at
some point if the FBI and this is what
I've asked people who've done this work
so they they clarified it for me at some
point when the FBI has completed their
work or has come across something that
causes concern they will go back to the
client and say this is what we found
just so you're aware of it you have to
make the decision client because you're
the one who's going to
the security clearance so in this case I
think it was if they were talking to the
two ex-wives and her there are
indications or accusations of domestic
abuse that would be something that the
FBI would definitely note go back run it
to ground make sure that it's accurate
that it's not just the what we call a
poison pen just not somebody who's angry
but that there's actually validity to
the complaint that the allegation can be
substantiated to some level and then
they go back to the client and say this
could be a problem but again the FBI
does not issue the security clearance
and if you have a criminal that in this
case it was just an accusation there
were no criminal charges against Rob
Porter but if you did have them are you
automatically disqualified for that that
should disqualify you the general
standard is in a case where there is an
allegation or if there's anything that
impinges upon your good character
something that makes you possibly prone
to blackmail or just shows again bad
character the the party that is
sponsoring your clearance should drop
you so you don't you don't have to be
convicted you know it's all up to the
the person who's requesting the security
clearance I think I read yesterday that
six people were who are on interim
clearances in the White House have just
been let go again the White House should
want to make sure that everybody that
they bring in is are pristine with no
problems because if something were to
happen at a later time and information
is lost or if a person who was pushed
through and given a clearance despite
warnings and FBI investigation if that
person turns out to then violate the
security procedures
it just makes everybody look bad you
know and could possibly put people up
for criminal charges okay Gerald and
Crowley Louisiana Democrat Gerald good
morning
parents information about security and I
was scared cause they don't make sense
to me well okay so Jeff wrinkled the hat
the hill newspaper has this headline
more than a hundred White House staffers
still work on temporary security
clearances a year after the election so
is that unusual I would think that's
unusual that the use of interim
clearances is not unusual in itself when
a president comes on board or when new
people come into the government these
background checks take from six months
to nine months generally they could even
take longer depending on if you are a
person who has a lot of things that need
to be investigated so they could take
longer but they should be wrapped up
after about nine months the White House
or the ones who are issuing the interim
clearances and then the FBI is going out
vetting the information and then coming
back to the White House saying
everything looks good
White House you make your decision but
to have that many people still an
interim clearances you know they should
have their clearances by now Jeff
wringle former FBI agent we thank you
for your time this morning joining us
for this conversation thank you
we're going to take a break when we come
back the National Association of
assistant US Attorney's president will
be here Lawrence Lizer to discuss the
Florida shooting but also changes to
criminal justice policy under the
Attorney General Jeff Sessions and then
later more of your calls and comments
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this weekend on American history TV on
c-span three Saturday at 8 p.m. Eastern